vous le disais il ya quelques minutes en
ouverture du journal quarante ans après
l'abbé pierre vient donc de lancer un
nouvel appel en faveur des sans abri
l'appel de 54 avaient déclenché une
vague de solidarité tout à fait
extraordinaire aujourd'hui ce sont
surtout les élus qui sont sollicités
voici cet appel en avant-première
écoutez bien mes amis réveillon à sède
indifférente
c'est la guerre la guerre de défense
contre la misère qui attaquent l'univers
total des sommes en europe
le savez vous 40 millions de personnes
vivent en dessous du seuil de la
pauvreté dans les banlieues dans les
cités de nos grandes villes des
générations de jeunes sont laissés à
l'abandon sans espoir de logements sans
projet sans avenir
est-ce qu'il faut attendre des
catastrophes bien visibles bien filmé
pour enfin se mobiliser ce cri s'adresse
à chacun d'entre nous et en premier à
vous mes compagnons et amis à vous tous
qui écouter et surtout à vous les plus
jeunes
ensemble nous avoue à détruire la misère
qui agressent la planète entière
elle surgit de partout à chacun de nous
à nous tous ensemble
audacieux sans merci sans repos de la
vaincre beaucoup de municipalités et
plus que toutes celles de certaines
grandes villes trahissent oui trahissent
en refaisant leur gîte aux plus faibles
la france ne doit plus laisser de
logique vide ni de bureaux vides ni
surtout laisser détruire des lieux
habitables sans immédiate nécessité
commandes et cela est abominable et pète
criminelle
la france doit bâtir immédiatement et
peuvent tous elle en a les moyens
l'argent la technique la main d'oeuvre
le sol vous les élus il est temps d'agir
pour que tout le monde est un logement
je voulais déjà tant demandée par parole
et par écrit et en actes
vous tous les citoyens écrivez à votre
mère lancé des pétitions
déposez les dans vos mairie avant le 15
mars pour qu'elle précède nos prochaines
initiatives communes
voilà vous l'avez compris c'était il ya
quelques minutes seulement quasiment en
direct sur l'antenne de rtl avec la même
force de conviction la même
détermination qu'en février 1954